>> Laura: AND THAT'S THE
ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT, MY NEXT GUEST IS
TAKING A LOT OF HEAT FOR MAKING
THIS BOLD PREDICTION.
>> THE TRUMPS WILL BE A DYNASTY
THAT WILL LAST FOR DECADES
PROPELLING THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
INTO A NEW PARTY.
>> Laura: BRAD PARSCALE WHO IS
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER, THE
YOUNGEST I THINK EVER TO MANAGE
A NATIONAL CAMPAIGN, YOU ARE
GETTING A LOT OF BACKLASH FOR
THAT STATEMENT.
EVEN LOU FROM FOX BUSINESS TO
HIT YOU SAYING THIS MAY BE ONE
OF THE DUMBEST THINGS I CAMPAIGN
MANAGER EVER SAID.
JOINING ME NOW EXCLUSIVELY,
BRAD PARSCALE.
BRAD, YOU SAID THAT OUT THERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS A BIG FUND-RAISER AND I
GET WHAT DOBBS IS SAYING.
THIS IS A MOVEMENT ABOUT
AMERICA.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE NAME TRUMP.
IT HE LET IT AND HE IS BOLD TO
DO IT BUT IT'S GOING TO GO ON
BEYOND HIM.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT DOBBS WAS
BRISTLING AT.
SO WHAT --
>> LET ME EXPLAIN.
THIS IS A JUGGERNAUT IN BUSINESS
AND NOW THEY ARE A JUGGERNAUT IN
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SO
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SW
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SI
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SS
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO ST
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SA
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SI
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SW
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO ST
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SH
POLITICS AND WHAT I WANTED TO SD
HOW HARD THIS FAMILY WORKED IN
2016 AND HOW HIGH THEY ARE
WORKING OUT AND I WILL WANT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO KNOW
THAT NO.
THIS FAMILY IS GOING TO BE WITH
THEM FOR THE FUTURE AND I JUST
WANTED PEOPLE TO SEE THAT AND I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT.
>> Laura: DO YOU MEAN BE
PRESIDENT FOR YEARS TO COME?
>> NO.
I JUST MEAN HELPING THEM FUND
RAISE, HAVING THE POLICIES OF
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUED,
CONTINUING TO FIGHT FOR THIS
GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT.
THIS MOVEMENT IS HUGE AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN IT SO FAR
AND I THINK EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO KNOW IF THIS
IS GOING TO BE CONTINUED.
>> Laura: SEE WE CAN SEEMED
THOUGH THAT THEY WERE DYNASTY --
IF HE HAD TO SAY IT AGAIN, WOULD
YOU SAY DYNASTY?
I SAY THINGS ALL THE TIME AND
I'M LIKE I SHOULDN'T OF SAW
THAT.
>> I MEAN THIS IS DIFFERENT.
IF YOU'RE PLAYING THE SPURS ON
THE LAKERS YOU WANT TO DYNASTY
BUT I GUESS HERE YOU DON'T
BUT --
>> Laura: THE DYNASTY IS A
PHILOSOPHY REALLY.
POPULACE, ECONOMICS,
NATIONALIST.
>> RIGHT.
IT'S FOR THEM TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS FAMILY --
I WAS TRYING TO EXPLAIN HOW HARD
THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS TO GO
THROUGH.
WHAT HE HAS GIVEN UP IN HIS
PERSONAL LIFE, HOW HARD HE
FIGHTS EVERY DAY, THE ENERGY HE
GIVES.
I WAS TRYING TO MAKE THEM
FEEL --
THEY ARE ALL OUT THERE BY
THEMSELVES IN CALIFORNIA AND I
WANT THEM TO UNDERSTAND THAT
HE'S GOING TO FIGHT FOR THEM.
TODAY HE TALKED ABOUT THE THREE
OR FOUR DISTRICTS THAT ARE GOING
TO FIGHT OUT THERE.
HOW ARE THESE PEOPLE ARE
FIGHTING OUT THERE.
WHAT'S ALREADY OCCURRING IN THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE ON THE
TICKET IN 2020 AND WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITY IS AND I TOLD THE
MOTHER THE SKY'S THE LIMIT.
>> Laura: I MEAN THAT IT IS
ACTUALLY CRAZY.
IT TRIGGERS ALL THE PEOPLE ON
THE LEFT.
SPEAK OF THE MEDIA THAT FREAKED
OUT WHEN THEY HEARD THAT THEY
ARE HAFTED DEALING WITH THIS FOR
POSSIBLY THE REST OF THIS LIVE
AND THE REAL THING IS, ONE OF
THEM TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
NOT JUST A ONE ELECTION OR TO
ELECTION THING.
THIS IS A MOVEMENT THAT IS GOING
TO CONTINUE WELL PAST INTO THE
FUTURE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO MOVE ON TO
SOME OTHER TOPICS.
FIRST I WANT TO GET YOUR OPINION
THAT WARREN AND HILLARY CLINTON
ARE TALKING BEHIND THE SCENES AS
THE 2020 RACE INTENSIFIES.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK SHE IS
GOING TO BE THE NOMINEE.
BIDEN IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO
FADE AWAY SO WARREN IS ON THE
RISE.
LET'S SAY SHE GETS THE
NOMINATION OF YOUR LOOKS LIKE
HILLARY IS GOING TO FINGER SOME
ADVICE.
>> I THINK THIS IS FUNNY.
I HOPE SHE GIVES THEM ALL KINDS
OF ADVICE.
STIGLITZ TALK ABOUT WHAT ELSE IS
HAPPENING IS THE DEMOCRATS PLAN
TO SLIP A NUMBER OF STATES.
EVERYONE WANTS TO FLIP STATES OR
CALL THEM, THAT'S HOW YOU WENT
GREAT I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING
THAT WAS SAID RECENTLY ABOUT
THIS.
WATCH.
>> HOW MANY DO YOU THINK YOU
COULD REASONABLY FLIP?
>> SIX.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, WE ARE COMING
AT YOU TEXAS.
WE DOVE TO THE WORD TO EXODUS
AND I THINK IT'S GENIUS.
I LOVE IT.
THEY'VE GOT AN ISSUE ON THEIR
HAND.
>> Laura: I HAVE FRIENDS IN
TEXAS WHO ARE NOT THINKING IT'S
GOING TO BE A CAKEWALK.
>> I THINK THOSE ELECTIONS THAT
ARE ALWAYS TOUGH.
I STILL THINK TEXAS IS CLEARLY
IN THE WIN COLUMN FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK THERE'S A COUPLE OF
SEATS THAT HAVE KIND OF CONDUCT.
I DON'T THINK TEXAS IS IN PLAY
IN 2020.
I THINK FROM THE LEFT, THIS IS
SOMETHING THEY WANT TO HEAR.
I THINK THIS HELPS THEM FUND
RAISE.
IT HELPS THEM FUND RAISE.
THEY WANT THAT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
ALL THEY HAVE HIS HATRED FOR MY
BOSS.
THEY HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO RUN ON
SO THEY ARE TRYING TO SAY HEY,
THERE'S SOMETHING OCCURRING.
>> Laura: WHAT CANDIDATE
CONCERNS YOU THE MOST?
>> WE CAN PREPARE FOR ALL THE
CANDIDATES.
IT'S NOT LIKE I DESIGNATE ONE.
RIGHT NOW THE GAME PLAN IS TO
BUILD OUT A LARGE OPERATION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND I THINK
THAT WE ARE SHOWING THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE 2 MILLION
TRAINED VOLUNTEERS.
AS MULTIPLES OF WHAT WE HAD IN
2016.
THERE ARE STATES WHERE LAST TIME
OUR BUDGET WAS $30,000 AND THE
STOMACH OF THE 20 OR OR 30 OR
$40 MILLION.
WE ARE EXPANDING THAT MATH.
MINNESOTA IS IN PLANO,
NEW HAMPSHIRE, NEVADA,
NEW MEXICO.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT
NEW MEXICO?
NEW MEXICO, I'M HEARING FROM A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ISSUE THERE, AMONG
LATINOS, IT IS INCREDIBLY
MOTIVATING BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT IT.
>> AND THEY ARE FIGHTING AGAINST
CHINA AND WHAT'S GOING ON THERE.
THEY LOVE THAT ISSUE.
I KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
FIGHTING FOR THEM AND THEIR JOBS
AND THEIR ECONOMIC FUTURES.
AS WELL AS THAT, THEY ACTUALLY
SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IN THEIR STATES AND
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO WIN THERE AND IN EVERY POLL
AND EVERYTHING I'VE DONE, WE
CONTINUE TO CLIMB IN THAT STATE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE OUT
THERE NEXT WEEK IN ALBUQUERQUE
AND HE'S GOING TO GIVE THAT
MESSAGE.
>> Laura: EVERYONE SAYING
YOU'VE GOT A GET SUBURBAN WOMEN
BACK.
CAN YOU GET SUBURBAN WOMEN THAT?
>> YET.
STILL, I SAID AS ALL THE TIME,
WOMEN AND MOTHERS IN THIS
COUNTRY DO NOT WANT THEIR
CHILDREN INBRED LINES GIVING
MEDICAL CARE.
IT'S REALLY EASY RIGHT NOW WHEN
IT'S 20 OUT THERE AND THEY JUST
SAY OH, YEAH, THIS THING.
WHILE NATURALLY THEY HAVE TO
MAKE THAT CHOICE AND I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE CLEAR THEY SEE
THE PRESIDENT'S POLICIES AND HOW
THEY ARE WINNING FOR THE LOWEST